thermique donc être sur l'assassinât du
petit grégory à nouveau en panne
le couple interpellé hier et gardé à vue
a été libéré en fin d'après midi
comme le souligne le journal le matin
certains organes de presse avaient
conclu trop vite à l'inculpation sur
place a vu hier isabelle bechler encore
une piste qui semble s'écrouler dans l'
enquête sur l'assassinât de grégory
villemin
après une garde à vue de 24 heures ici à
la gendarmerie d'epinal bernard et
marie-ange laroche les cousins des
villemin ont été remis en liberté à deux
heures d'intervalle par une porte
dérobée
voilà qui met en cause la fiabilité des
analyses graphologiques sur lesquels le
juge se fondaient les experts avaient en
effet rapproché l'écriture de bernard
laroche de celle des lettres du corbeau
ces indications dont en tout cas pas
fait le poids devant la libye des époux
la roche à l'heure du crime
marie ange était à son travail à
gérardmer à 30 km de lépanges quant à
bernard laroche
il passait la fin d'après midi du 16
octobre avec une de ses nièces dans le
village de la ville à 15 kilomètres de
lépanges le juge se refuse à tout
commentaire ce soir faut-il en conclure
que l'anc est repart de zéro pour autant
les gendarmes affirment que non